okay I've been telling you now for
several weeks that we are going to
launch david pakman show Koffee we had
uh viewers submit possible names for the
david pakman show coffees and we now are
ready to announce the winners based on
voting at david pakman.com we are going
to have 2 roasts one will be espresso
and one will be drip coffee the winners
are freedom of the press freedom of the
press is going to be the drip coffee
roasts french press it just sounds to me
like freedom of the press Pat is the
drip coffee roasts I would have to agree
Brendan and then progressive wake-up
call which was also one of the winning
coffee names at the david pakman.com
poll is going to be the espresso roast
and to me progressive wake-up call
sounds like espresso right that's like a
shot of caffeine that'll really get you
up in the morning it makes sense to and
get you activated as a progressive as
well so the next step is i know we have
a lot of graphic designers in the
audience we want to get some labels done
for the coffee I believe the specs are
going to be four inches tall by three
inches wide this may change depending on
the final decisions made about the bags
but ideally you could do it in a
resolution that's high enough where it
could be scaled down or moved around in
necessary if necessary get in touch if
you want more details although I don't
really have more details it'll be four
inches tall by three inches wide we want
two labels one for progressive wake-up
call one for freedom of the press I'd
like to have the david pakman show logo
somewhere on the label and if you want
to pull that off of our website that's
fine if you want to email me or contact
me through our website contact form i
can send you the vector files for the
logo ipad and very excited to see what
the audience comes up with yeah i was
excited to see what they would come up
with for names yeah now that it's coming
down to labels i mean i just can't
control myself yeah pat has had to
actually be sedated in the mornings when
he comes in because he's just so wound
up over the coffee's in the entire thing
duh fortunately he's able to still
buckle down and get his work done when
it went when the rubber meets the road
Pat's ready to work